Power-ups are a classic game mechanic,
easily recognized by
anyone who has played a video
game in the last, actually ever.
Well, the first power-up was probably
introduced back in 1980 with Pac-Man.
And if there were power-ups
in video games before that,
I neither confirm nor deny that I'm
old enough to have collected them.
But anyway, a power-up is just an object
that gives the player some ability or
other benefit, like super speed,
additional ammo, an extra life.
You get the idea.
Of course, it's up to you whether or
not they appear in your game.
What they do, how and
when you let players collect them, and
there are a lot of options.
You can place them randomly or
at spots you preselect.
You can spawn them when an enemy dies or
a puzzle is completed.
You can make it so a player collects
power-ups just by touching them.
Or require some other, more involved
process, like smashing a chest, or
digging out a wall.
There's certainly nothing that says you
have to have power-ups in your game.
But they really have
stood the test of time.
I think most game players would
agree that they add something to
the experience.